Місце, де десятиліттями народжувалося життя…
І де його ледь не обірвала російська ракета.
Такий вигляд тепер має пологове відділення
однієї з лікарень Дніпра.
Он був приліт, якраз під фундамент.
Фактично в підвал цього пологового відділення прийшовся удар.
У результаті тут пожежа була.
Тут перекриття рухнуло вниз.
Приміщення на першому поверсі, в які влетіла ракета,
вигоріли вщент. Удар був такої сили, що кількатонні плити з бетону
просто повивертало в різні боки.
Ще 27 грудня у цих стінах Ольга Огійченко приймала пологи.
За два дні після цього відділення палало просто на її очах.
Я встала з автівки, відкрила задню дверцю,
щоб взяти свої речі й стався приліт.
Ми з моєю колегою, яка їхала зі мною на роботу,
встигли сісти назад. Вагітну жінку,
яка прийшла зранку на здачу аналізів, ми врятували.
Вона якраз заходила до приймального відділення
в момент прильоту. Жінка розгубилася, бігала по вулиці,
ми її взяли до себе в машину.
Таким чином уламки, які летіли, не пошкодили нікого.
У момент влучання в пологовому, крім медпрацівників,
перебували дев'ятнадцять пацієнток стаціонару,
а також четверо новонароджених.
Усі вони вціліли лише завдяки тому, що вчасно спустилися в укриття,
розповідають лікарі.
В пологах нікого не було,
в операційній нікого не оперували.
У нас всі жінки під час повітряної тривоги спускалися в укриття.
Таким чином саме 29 грудня були врятовані життя.
У частково зруйнований пологовий медпрацівники приходять ніби в гості до колишнього життя.
Хтось шукає свої особисті речі, а когось, як Катерину,
сюди привела ностальгія за улюбленою роботою.
Після другого курсу в мене тут працювала одногрупниця санітаркою.
Каже: "Хочеш?". Я кажу: "Звісно, хочу".
І я пішла, так. Спочатку я санітаркою працювала більше року.
Потім, як закінчила третій курс, змогла працювати медсестрою,
потім акушеркою. І минулого року я вже закінчила університет,
поступила на інтернатуру й стала тут лікарем-інтерном.
Свої робочі ранки Катерина починала з обходу пацієнтів.
За білими дверима зазвичай чекали породілля та немовлята,
а тепер, каже, в палати навіть моторошно зазирати.
Це троянди Олечки.
Вони 25 грудня стали батьками вдруге.
Я її навіть зранку зустрічала, ми готувалися до пологів.
Ці троянди подарував їй чоловік за народження другої донечки.
І це вони тут так і залишилися, бо ж тоді, 29 грудня,
по тривозі вони були спущені в укриття, й тут все так і залишилось.
Деякі речі потім забрали, а троянди так і стоять.
Ця частина будівлі вціліла найбільше.
Чимало медичного обладнання й побутових речей
звідси вдалося винести майже неушкодженими.
Тут був пост акушерки пологової зали.
Тут, де відчинені двері, була ординаторська,
де сиділи й чергували. А оце все - пологові зали.
Так, як тут найбільш вціліле приміщення,
ми знесли сюди деякі меблі та техніку.
В цій частині будівлі напередодні трагедії завершили ремонт.
Ми тільки нещодавно поставили ці двері гарні й тепер тут немає скла.
Тут також були вибиті всі вікна, все було завалено,
тому що ми все винесли звідси.
Майже тиждень після трагедії медпрацівники разом із рідними та друзями
розчищали завали і виносили сміття.
Також на допомогу прийшли десятки містян.
Ось це, до речі, стоїть бак.
Ще хлопці не винесли.
Тут скло, яке ми збирали в операційній,
тут, де операційна медсестра знаходилася.
Збирали, різали пальці на руках, на ногах,
тому що замітаєш і воно все піднімається.
Ці маленькі уламки залітають в чоботи.
Було порізано все.
За словами керівництва, медзаклад уже не вперше
потерпає від російської агресії.
Було 170 вікон вибито, відновили,
все зробили, працювало.
Зараз близько 900.
Розміри збитків ще не підраховували, але вони масштабні,
каже директор лікарні.
Нам допоможуть з вікнами.
Нам допомагають благодійники, різні організації.
Сподіваємося. А по відновленню пологового - це велике питання.
Ми також проводимо роботу з різними організаціями,
також проводимо роботу з нашим міністерством.
Якось вдасться.
Сумно, але ми намагаємося і в соціальних мережах
виставляти ролики для того, щоб небайдужі люди нам допомагали.
У нас відкритий рахунок, він прозорий.
Видно, скільки коштів надходить на цей рахунок.
Чи вдасться повністю відновити будівлю - наразі невідомо.
Тим часом найбільша мрія працівників  -
якнайшвидше відбудувати відділення,
аби у цих стінах знову народжувалися діти.
Це просто удар по серцю.
Дуже б хотілося, щоб відновили наш пологовий будинок.
Якнайшвидше. Тому що тут,
в пологовому, народжується життя.